السيناريو الاشد وطئه على العالم قد يتكرر
العوده الى مربع 2020 كورونا لم ينتهي بعد
وتحوراته الجديده لم تبدا ايضا
فصيله تواجه موجه كبيره وتسجل مقاطعه عند
اصابات بمئات الالف يوميا وقد تصل الى
مليون حاله يبدو هذا واضحا هنا في
المستشفيات ودور الجنازات يقول بعض
الاطباء ان المستشفيات تستقبل اعدادا اكبر
بخمسه الى سته امثال الى عدد المعتاد
معظمهم من كبار السن
الكبير حيث تجاوزت 500 زياره يوميا اعتدنا
على الفئتين الاولى والثانيه او الحالات
الحرجه التي تمثل 10 الى 15% من الاجمالي
لكن الان يمكن ان تصل ذروتها الى 40%
[موسيقى]
خصوصا بعد تخفيف القيود الصارمه المتعلقه
بالسياسه ركوفيت ولعل فتحه باب السفر اكثر
ما يقلق خصوصا بعد استئناف الصيني اصدار
جوازات سفر وتاشيرات جديده ما يعني موجات
مسافرين من الصين واليها
من المتوقع ان ترتفع اسعار التذاكر على
المدى القصير بسبب زياده الطلب
نعتقد ان بعض الاماكن في اسيا ستصبح وجهات
شعبيه في البدايه تليها اوروبا وامريكا
والعالم باسره
قرار ردت عليه الهند واليابان وماليزيا
بتشديد القواعد على الصينيين القادمين
فيما تدرس الولايات المتحده اجراءات
الممثله
رفع التدابير يعزز من احتمالات ظهور
سلالات جديده مختلفه عن مشاهده العالم في
السنوات الثلاثه الاخيره ولعل الافتقار
الى بيانات التسلسل الجميل للفيروس يصعبه
على مسؤوليه الصحه العامه اي حديد اي
متحولات جديده محتمله ومواجهتها
البعض منهم ملايين الاصابات وما لا يقل عن
وفاه المليون حال يوميا في الصين العمل
المقبل